this video recording may not show much
but for italian officials investigating
the brutal murder of giulio regina in
egypt
it's a breakthrough the first evidence
that the italian student was targeted
and put under surveillance by egyptian
authorities
it comes after italian prosecutors
announced plans to charge
four egyptian security officers with the
students torture and death
they say one of the defendants colonel
assa camal assigned the informant
to monitor giulia regene a month before
he was killed
arjuna is
today we know that the egyptian general
security followed virginia's tracks for
40 days
we know that he was arrested first in a
camp and transferred to cell number 13
of the egyptian ministry of interior
this is a very dangerous matter and the
italian people strongly condemn it
we firmly maintain our position with
respect to closing diplomatic ties with
egypt
regina's body was found on a desert
highway after he disappeared in january
2016.
he was last seen near an underground
subway stop in cairo
where he'd been researching the
sensitive topic of labor movements in
egypt
his mother later said his body was so
mutilated she was only able to recognize
the tip of his nose
rights groups say the marks resemble
those resulting from widespread torture
practices
in egyptian facilities the national
security agency
in egypt is quite notorious we have
documented
rampant torture we have documented
enforced disappearance in the country
and how the judiciary is effectively in
service
of the system of repression in the in
the
country the death sparked outrage in
italy and strained diplomatic relations
between the two countries
with italy's government accusing
egyptian authorities of non-cooperation
we want truth and justice for our
citizen who has been killed in tortured
in such a terrible way without an
explanation
egyptian prosecutors have continued to
insist that regene's killers remain
unknown
and authorities deny any involvement in
fact they've announced a temporary
suspension of the investigation
but italy plans to push on with the case
regardless the suspects will be tried in
an italian court in abstentia
as for giulio regina's parents they're
still calling for justice for their son
his mother applauded an investigation
that not only shed some light on his
death
but held up what she called a mirror of
how human rights are violated in egypt
every day
khara leg al jazeera